but Tory of joining big franchises were
you very nervous Jack Whitehall joining
a big Disney franchise like frozen so
frozen I was very excited when the call
came in because I'm a massive Disney fan
and frozen called me up so we're making
this film and we'd love you to be a part
of it I was like yup sign me up which
princess am i playing I played at role
in the film I have one line in the film
but I was like yeah I'd love to do it
I learned my line I went in I absolutely
I'm not
you nailed it I nailed it absolutely it
was so good and then I told everyone
that was in frozen I did a press junk in
front of the poster I was so excited and
then six months later popped on the
black tie went down to the Odeon in
Putney it wasn't a premiere it was a
mistake I watched the film got to the
end and the line wasn't there so I
called my agent I was like there must be
some kind of mistake
this must be some different director
Scott that I've seen and she went oh no
I forgot to tell you I got an email
about this and they said that they have
reduced your part in the film to a
non-speaking role
and what the worst things then becomes
the biggest film ever
I love the film hey every time I watch
it it's like getting an icy dagger to my
heart song as well is like they're
heckling me because your character is
still in it yeah so you can see the
character and he goes through it with as
well mouki the troll are you working
with a frozen yeah yeah yeah I just
worked with Josh um Josh GAD yes and
honor on a beauty of the beast for
distributing the booty and the candle
you are really good at rubbing it in
this evening
yeah yeah they're not cutting out
Lumiere Lumiere's in yeah I'm chair the
fret I've been living with a front I'm
married to a Frenchman 20 years more
than 20 years and I thought yeah I've
can do the French accent I got there and
I couldn't know me is people that
service to the test
yes
you see I it's why did and they said no
don't do that don't do the her don't
they didn't want the French huh
so when you take the French huh and you
do an or you suddenly become totally
Mexican we are gas we are again test I
mean the glass I can see the ball going
okay just wait a minute you know [ __ ] I
can't do it so I'm gonna have to redo my
all my voice I think you go maybe I'll
get you over they'll probably cut it yes
and that would mean that would cut me so
I'll do that yogurt I'll work on it
because what you Louis you were in them
cars too
and what am using character did you play
in cars to muscle do it several
languages why I like had about three
lines and I didn't for different
languages there's just a conversation
with Queen Creek also didn't Spanish
German and French English oh and have
you seen the film oh yeah what
you're sure you're in it because I could
and I was on the only car that didn't
blow up so I'm hoping to come back for
number three cars three pick apart not
exactly
I am i do love Disney but the other
reason that Disney is not ruined for me
is because I went to the Disney hotel
have you ever been to the Disney hotel I
was doing work in America I was there
for a month and I love Disney bits to
Disney there's like Disney everywhere
Disney wallpaper music yeah is for kids
just working for the Disney Corporation
so I think they're trying to save some
money not weird Oprah
these have Disney staff members so like
characters so like Goofy's doing
teppanyaki in the restaurant you get a
wake-up call it's Daffy duck's voice
you're coming yeah there's that they're
walking around the hotel but the moment
that my child had died was like I think
it was about two weeks in I was very
tired and alone I was in my room and I
called down to the front desk and it was
Mickey Mouse's voice he's like hey hey
hey buddy what can I do for you today
Mickey I need to activate the portal
channels on my TV
thirty-six and I don't have a driver's
license I'm intrigued to know what do
you what how does it man not have a
drive like am i right and I started to
talk to her and she was like um she's
like no you you you speak that way first
and I'll speak this way and I come back
to you